and welcome to Hannity and tonight we
are broadcasting a beautiful Acworth
Georgia welcome Georgia thank you for
being here
in mere moments we will be joined by
Republican Senate candidate Herschel
Walker along with Senator Lindsey Graham
and Senator Tim Scott for an exclusive
Hannity Town Hall
[Music]
we are a mere 22 days away from a
Tipping Point election for the direction
of this country Democrats they are
pouring tens and tens of millions of
dollars and resources into this state
and many others in what is a desperate
attempt to defeat smear slander Herschel
Walker last night they attempted to
Ambush Herschel Walker at a fake debate
that was organized by a group of
individuals who quote donated thousands
of dollars to Democrats including Joe
Biden Georgia Democratic senator John
ossoff and even Raphael Warnock who was
in the debate the Atlanta Press Club
director who is in charge of the Sham
debate donated to both Joe Biden and
Arizona Democrat Mark Kelly now another
member of the Press Club donated
thousands to Rafael Warnock why would
Herschel ever show up in an environment
like that and yet another member donated
500 to the Democratic senatorial
Campaign Committee and yet another
member of the Atlanta Press Club donated
500 dollars to Warnock so after Herschel
Walker refused to play along they put uh
an empty Podium to try and shame him for
not attending their fake debate well we
will be the antidote to that tonight
much of the media in Atlanta and
Nationwide they are petulant radical
extreme left-wing bullies they don't
tell the truth they despise Herschel
Walker they despise every conservative
they don't like the fact that he's a
conservative he thinks for himself and
he is long rejected the radical
socialist beliefs of this new green New
Deal socialist Democratic party and
steady supports what low taxes how do we
do we need energy independence energy
Independence uh do we need Law and Order
we need Law and Order do we need a
secure border do we need peace through
strength how about schools that are not
woke that teach Reading Writing Math
Science History
right not wolf propaganda now despite
this very pragmatic agenda Democrats the
mob and the media like the AJC and
others they would like the people in
Georgia to believe in the people around
the country to believe that Herschel
Walker is not worthy of being a U.S
senator but in Friday night's debate
Herschel Walker proved them all wrong
and he won that debate here are some
highlights
he told me black lives matter and if you
think about it senator in Atlanta
Georgia there's more black baby that is
aborted than uh than anything so if
black lives matter why are you not
protecting those babies and instead of
the boarding those babies why are you
not baptizing those babies to hear
Senator Warner talks about supporting
law enforcement is sad because he's
called them names and because of the
name caller he's done the morale is down
recruitment is down only because of what
he's done he's empowered criminals
to think they're better than the police
what I would do is hold people
accountable which is centered why not
not do it believing in no cash Bail no
accountability that is a problem people
must be accountable for their action and
the truth lies with Senator Warner
because he said he was doing the
Washington to represent Georgia he went
to Washington to represent Joe Biden Mr
Walker former president Trump is also
considering a run for the White House in
2024 if you can give me a simple yes or
no answer and when it's time to explain
as well would you support a trump 2024
run yes I would now if you watch the
debate how many of you noticed that
Raphael Warnock wouldn't answer a
question
he wouldn't answer the question about uh
would he support Joe Biden wanted no
part of that question at all I wouldn't
answer a lot of questions do you have
any exceptions on abortion he wouldn't
answer Herschel Walker is a
constitutional conservative but if
elected he could very well be the 51st
Republican vote in the U.S Senate in
other words for all of you around the
country understand this Herschel Walker
could be the last line of defense
against Biden's radical leftist new
green deal socialist horrible agenda
that is especially impacting the poor
the middle class and people on fixed
incomes in this country that's why
Democrats are all in for a radical
candidate with a lot of baggage take a
look
America nobody can serve God and the
military no matter what happens next
month more than a third of the nation
that would go along with this is reason
to be afraid
America needs to repent for its worship
of whiteness
on on full display we remember Fidel
Castro whose Legacy is complex
don't let anybody tell you A Simple
Story life usually isn't very simple
his legacy is complex
kind of like America's Legacy is complex
Warnock praising Castro he also lavished
Praise on anti-American preacher the one
that said GD America Reverend Jeremiah
Wright and by the way even noted
anti-semite Louis farrakhani he he preys
on him as well he compared police to
Thugs and gangsters he supports
eliminating all cash bail as a senator
he voted to uphold Biden's oil and gas
bans is vowed to end all new fossil fuel
leases and to go to quote renewable
energies whatever that is it is not
really clear that Warnock supports any
restrictions on abortion at all he would
not answer that question in the in the
debate on Friday including up to the
moment of birth but of course the media
the mob they won't ask him about those
extreme positions meanwhile as a pastor
warnock's character has been called into
question many times in 2002 as a
minister in West Baltimore Warnock was
arrested literally arrest did for
obstructing a police investigation into
a child abuse cases multiple cases at
his church camp and according to the
Baltimore Sun he blocked the police from
interviewing Camp counselors that were
key to the case and ultimately Warnock
himself was not convicted of any crime
but five cases of child abuse at his
Camp were brought against one of his
Camp directors who Warnock was clearly
trying to protect more recently in 2020
Warnock was accused of running over his
wife with a car during a domestic
dispute take a look at this
and he just starts backing the car up
and he wasn't going fast like I'm not
I'm not bleeding but
I can't believe he would have run me
open so you think it was attention
I think obviously I was standing here
the door is open and I'm leaning into
the car how can you drive the car when
I'm leaning into it he knew it was a
risk and he doesn't care he just cares
about his own stuff he's got a flight to
catch and that's all that matters this
man's running for the United States
Senate and all he cares about right now
is his reputation I've tried to keep the
way that he acts under wraps for a long
time and today he crossed the line he's
like I have to draw the line today I've
had enough of him thinking he can do
whatever he wants because of who he is
and treat me any kind of way and I just
keep taking it and being quiet for his
reputation sake and I've had it
now we must ask why was Warnock not
arrested and now by the way why is
nobody in the Democratic party you know
where are all the believe all women
caucus where are those Democrats openly
disturbed by those allegations you just
heard and get this even more recently
this year Warnock was ordered by a
superior court judge to attend mediation
after he was accused of neglecting his
own children and failing to pay child
care expenses despite amassing a net
worth of nearly one million dollars
Warnock now draws two incomes not only
is Warnock a full-time U.S senator but
he also earns a large six-figure
paycheck as the senior pastor of
Ebenezer Baptist Church the church was
also generously providing Warnock with a
seven thousand four hundred dollar
monthly housing allowance but here's the
kicker according to a bombshell new
report from the Washington Free Beacon
eviction notices have been sent to a
dozen residents for past due rent at an
investment property owned by warnock's
quote Church they even attempted to
evict one resident who owed just 28
dollars now tonight Herschel Walker has
offered to cover any and all rent for
anybody that is facing eviction at the
building that is owned by Raphael
warnock's church but keep in mind
warnock's church had nearly 1.2 million
dollars with cash on hand at the end of
2021. so if you want to see an obvious
example of greed and Corruption Warnock
says that he's against then look no
further than the senior pastor of
Ebenezer Baptist Church who has been
laughing all the way to the bank all
while his own policies heard his own
constituents inflation 41-year High
because of the bills that he passed gas
prices more than double what we were
paying under President Trump in many
states even more because of the energy
restrictions that people like Raphael
Warnock support and soon an army of 8 87
000 IRS agents they will be descending
uh on Georgia's small businesses because
of legislation that Warnock
enthusiastically supported here's the
deal in 22 days if you want to hold
Biden accountable if you want to turn
our economy around and you want a
reliable 51st conservative vote in the
U.S Senate you have to go to the polls
you have the power make no mistake this
race is incredibly close a brand new
just for the show Insider Advantage poll
now have Warnock and Walker neck and
neck within the margin of error it's a
two-point race hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else